perhaps looking for us to be fair men
there's always snoring is it are you
ready to go yeah what's your favorite
moment from being the safe banker we're
not
[Applause]
how good is this current group of
England players it's the best every age
the future what was it like on your
first day of training did they go easy
on you and they talk how was it I went
off on them to be there no lesson about
who's the better dresser many more
pep-pep so professed to prefer what
about Mindy style is that something
you're gonna adopt you know just like
him
sometimes it's alright sometimes it's a
bit rash what's your favorite sport
outside of football or my fishing yeah
what's the biggest mystery of a core
under the first six pound catfish really
yeah you were in the new night
celebration Jersey made up of the last
kits and past six years but how many
different colors make up this [ __ ]
that's a lot yes I occasionally you kick
ups can you do it oh really
it is I counted seven colors on there
and it's made up of the last eight coach
men there's always stores
company or fernandinho
is harder hard to say I think vignette
yeah who is the funniest member of the
squad Mendy
who's the most skillful Russ Leroy
get a bunch of different people who when
you cook well yeah my games not really
still for what's your game that sounds
simple keep it simple ah dribble there
in there now are you confident that's it
can still win the league yeah have you
been surprised at how good other rivals
have been trouble yeah definitely
because we've got a lot of points though
this year yes it's been good this year
what's different central actually
obviously in the centurions hundred
points what is the difference why aren't
city running away of it just yet the
teams have got better and stronger now
final final questions alright
worst-dressed why who is the worst
dresser City Bernardo oh crap looks like
a skill teacher how many months of the
year have 28 days Oh
10 I don't know they all have 28 oh [ __ ]
question this is Phil folding
nice one well done top stuff
[Music]
you